When we think about politics, many of us think it's all about debates. Arguments about things like immigration. It's called extreme vetting. There are children suffering in this catastrophic war. Or perhaps we think politics is a way to achieve our economic goals. The Secretary Clinton, you're calling for a tax increase in the wealthiest Americans. And Mr. Trump, you're calling for tax cuts for the wealthy. Well, I'm really calling for major jobs because the wealthy are going to create tremendous jobs.
当我们在思考政治时，许多人认为这全关乎辩论。关于移民等事情的争论。这被称为极端审查。在这个灾难性的战争中，有儿童在受苦。或者也许我们认为政治是实现我们经济目标的一种方式。克林顿女士，你呼吁对最富有的美国人加税。而特朗普先生，你呼吁为富人减税。嗯，我其实是在呼吁创造大量的工作岗位，因为富人将会创造巨大的工作岗位。
Trickle down did not work. It got us into the mess we were in in 2008 and 2009. But here's the thing. Economists, psychologists and journalists have long noted a paradox. Economists, psychologists, and journalists have long noted a paradox. Millions of Americans seem to ignore their ideologies and their economic interests when it comes to voting. Working class people often vote for conservatives who promise tax cuts for the wealthy. Liberal elites, whom I personally benefit from a less progressive tax code, are often the ones arguing most strongly for higher taxes and economic safety nets. In the 1990s, Democrats who decried the powerful taking advantage of the week rallied behind President Bill Clinton after he was caught having an affair with an intern. More recently,
向下渗透（经济学）并未奏效。它让我们陷入了2008年和2009年的困境。但事情是这样的。经济学家、心理学家和记者长期以来一直注意到一个悖论。经济学家、心理学家和记者长期以来一直注意到一个悖论。数百万美国人在投票时似乎忽略了他们的意识形态和经济利益。工人阶级经常投票给承诺为富人减税的保守派。我个人受益于不太累进的税制自由派精英，往往是最力主更高税收和经济安全网的人。在20世纪90年代，谴责权贵利用弱势群体的民主党人，在比尔·克林顿总统被发现与实习生有染后，纷纷聚集在他身后。最近，
family values conservatives supported the thrice-married Donald Trump even after he boasted about groping women. Why do people seemingly vote against their interests and their values? One hypothesis, voting is less about ideology and economics and more about expressing our emotional needs. I've watched my country go from a place where I felt safe to a very unsafe world. I don't feel safe anymore here. The forgotten men and women of our country will be forgotten no longer. I also want to tell the children not to be afraid because we are not alone.
注重家庭价值观的保守派支持结过三次婚的唐纳德·特朗普，甚至在他夸耀对女性动手动脚之后也是如此。为什么人们似乎会违背自己的利益和价值观进行投票？一个假设是，投票与其说是关于意识形态和经济，不如说是关于表达我们的情感需求。我看着我的国家从一个让我感到安全的地方变成了一个非常不安全的世界。我在这里再也没有安全感了。我们国家被遗忘的男男女女将不再被遗忘。我也想告诉孩子们不要害怕，因为我们并不孤单。
This week on Hidden Brain, what if politics is less aboutan. We all have stories. Stories about our traditions, stories about our setbacks, stories about our dreams. These stories shape our identity. They help us define who's on our side and who's not. My guest today explores how such stories shape the way we think about politics. Arleigh Hokeshield is a sociologist at the University of California at Berkeley and the author of the book Strangers in their own land, Anger and Morning on the American right. She's a liberal who has spent years talking to people who politically disagree with her in an attempt to understand what she calls their deep story. Arlie, welcome to Hidden Brain. Well, thank you very much. I'm delighted to be here. So you decided a few years ago to head out
本周的《隐藏的大脑》节目，如果政治与其说是关于……我们都有故事。关于我们的传统的故事，关于我们的挫折的故事，关于我们的梦想的故事。这些故事塑造了我们的身份。它们帮助我们定义谁站在我们这边，谁没有。我今天的嘉宾探讨了这些故事是如何塑造我们对政治的看法的。阿利·霍克希尔德（Arlie Hochschild）是加州大学伯克利分校的社会学家，也是《自己土地上的陌生人：美国右翼的愤怒与哀悼》一书的作者。她是一个自由派，花了多年时间与在政治上与她意见相左的人交谈，试图理解她所说的他们的“深层故事”。阿利，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。我很荣幸能来到这里。所以你几年前决定出发，
from Berkeley and spend extended amounts of time in Louisiana to understand the views of conservatives. Tell me what motivated this project. Why did you go? Five years ago, I already felt like a lot of others that I was living in an enclave and that other Americans with different political views were living in their enclaves. And that I didn't understand the people with whom I knew I had deep disagreements. So I decided to get out of my enclave in Berkeley, California, kind of a progressive democratic town, and find an equal and opposite
离开伯克利，在路易斯安那州度过了很长一段时间，以了解保守派的观点。告诉我是什么促使了这个项目？你为什么去？五年前，我和许多其他人一样，觉得自己生活在一个飞地里，而其他有不同政治观点的美国人则生活在他们自己的飞地里。而且我不理解那些我知道自己与他们存在深刻分歧的人。所以我决定离开我在加州伯克利——一个进步的民主党城市——的飞地，去找一个对立面，
uncleith, which was as far right as Berkeley, California is left. I looked in 2012 at the proportion of whites that voted for Brock Obama in his reelection. It was about half in California. For the whole region of the South, it was a third and in Louisiana, it was 12%. So I thought, wow, let me go there. So you went out to Louisiana long before Donald Trump announced that he was running for president, but you say that he happened to come along at a point when three distinct forces were in place. Many older heterosexual married whites feel their economic lives are unstable, that their cultural views are often painted as outmoded, and that demographic changes are turning them into a minority. Together you say
一个与伯克利一样极右的飞地，就像伯克利左倾一样。我在2012年查看了投票支持巴拉克·奥巴马连任的白人比例。在加州大约是一半。在整个南方地区是三分之一，而在路易斯安那州是12%。所以我想，哇，让我去那儿看看。所以你早在唐纳德·特朗普宣布竞选总统之前很久就去了路易斯安那州，但你说他恰好在一个存在三种截然不同力量的时刻出现。许多年长的异性恋已婚白人感到他们的经济生活不稳定，他们的文化观点经常被描绘成过时的，人口结构的变化正在把他们变成少数族裔。你认为，这些共同作用产生了
these produce a sense of pervasive anxiety, of feeling that they are strangers in their own land. Can you give me a couple of specific examples of how the people you spoke with express those anxieties? Yes, I met a woman whose husband hadn't had a raise in 20 years. She hadn't had one in a decade. So they were doing okay, but they weren't advancing, even though they worked extremely long hours. And she said, you know, I know you people on the coasts think that we in the south are old fashioned and ill-educated.
一种普遍的焦虑感，觉得自己是自己土地上的陌生人。你能给我举几个具体的例子，说明你交谈过的人是如何表达这些焦虑的吗？是的，我遇到过一个女人，她的丈夫20年没涨过工资了。她自己也有十年没涨过了。所以他们过得还行，但没有进步，尽管他们工作时间极长。她说，你知道，我知道你们沿海地区的人认为我们南方人老土、没文化。
And we know the epithets that you people apply to us, that we are homophobic, that we are home of pho-bic, that we're racist, that we're sexist. So she felt humiliated and put down, and like a whole way of life, and a kind of people was going out. They almost felt like Native Americans. They felt like another minority group that didn't have a name. You talk to many people for many hours on end, you made repeated visits back to Louisiana,
而且我们知道你们这些人给我们贴上的标签，说我们恐同，说我们恐……同，说我们种族歧视，说我们性别歧视。所以她感到被羞辱和贬低，就像一种生活方式和一类人正在消失一样。他们几乎觉得自己像美洲原住民。他们觉得自己就像另一个没有名字的少数群体。你和许多人进行了长时间的交谈，你多次重返路易斯安那州，
and then you constructed something that you call a deep story. It's a story that you say feels emotionally true. It captures, as you say, the hopes, fears, pride, shame, resentment, and anxiety of people. And since the story is so central to your book, I want to spend some time with it, it's a story that you tell in three scenes. And part one is something you'll call waiting in line. Right. In this scene, you're waiting in line as in a pilgrimage, it's facing up a hill at the top of which is the American dream. Your feet are tired, you've been in that line a long time, the line is not moving, and you don't have any ill will as you experience yourself
然后你构建了一些你称之为“深层故事”的东西。这是一个你认为在情感上感觉真实的故事。正如你所说，它捕捉到了人们的希望、恐惧、骄傲、羞耻、怨恨和焦虑。既然这个故事对你的书如此核心，我想花点时间来探讨它，这是一个你分为三个场景讲述的故事。第一部分是你所谓的“排队”。对的。在这个场景中，你像进行朝圣一样在排队，面向一座山，山的顶端是美国梦。你的脚很累，你已经在队伍里排了很久，队伍没有移动，在你经历这一切时，你对任何人都没有恶意，但你全神贯注于获得你付出的辛勤努力所应得的回报这一目标。
toward anyone, but you are quite riveted on the goal of getting some reward for the hard work that you've put in. And scene two, you notice a head that somebody seems to be cutting in line. I think how unfair, it's just not right. I obey the rules, I'm not cutting in line, and somebody else is. I obey the rules, I'm cutting in line, and somebody else is. So, who are these line cutters? Well, they are blacks who, through affirmative action, have access to jobs formally reserved for whites, their women, much larger group, who now have access to jobs formally reserved for men. They're immigrants, refugees, and in your perception, even public sector workers. Actually, also cutting in line for these Louisiana's would be the endangered brown pelican
在场景二中，你注意到有人似乎在插队。我想，这太不公平了，这不对。我遵守规矩，我没有插队，而别人却在插队。我遵守规矩，我在插队，而别人却在插队。那么，这些插队的人是谁呢？好吧，他们是通过平权行动获得原本留给白人的工作机会的黑人，是获得原本留给男人的工作机会的规模大得多的女性群体，他们是移民、难民，在你的感知中，甚至是公共部门的工作人员。事实上，对于路易斯安那州人来说，插队的还有面临灭绝危险的棕鹈鹕，
with its oil drenched wings. Because I many times heard people say, well, you know, these environmentalists are putting animals ahead of us people. So all this happens, and then you turn around and you see that the supervisor of this long line, the person designated to keep order in it, Barack Obama Obama seems to be signaling to the people who have cut it in line. He seems to be sponsoring them and egging them on, encouraging them. So you think, well, wait a minute. He's not taking care of me. He's setting me back because my position in line is going backward.
它那沾满石油的翅膀。因为我多次听到人们说，好吧，你知道，这些环保主义者把动物放在我们人前面。所以这一切都发生了，然后你转过身去，看到这个长队的主管，那个被指派维持秩序的人——巴拉克·奥巴马，似乎在向那些插队的人发出信号。他似乎在资助他们、怂恿他们、鼓励他们。所以你会想，等等。他没有照顾我。他在让我倒退，因为我在队伍中的位置在后退。
And then they felt in this line as they're pushed back and injustice had been done. So when people sort of internalize the story, the story, this feeling that you're waiting in line, that people are cutting in line, and that the people who are supposed to be minding the line and maintaining order are in some ways betraying how the line is supposed to operate. That this deep story, when you ran this story by the people you met and befriended, many of them told you that you had captured something that fell true to them. So many liberals, for example, might say that conservatives are being brainwashed by Fox News, you would say, no, the appeal of Fox is that they confirm to people
然后他们在队伍中感到被推后，不公已经造成。因此，当人们某种程度上将这个故事内化时，这个故事，即你在排队、人们在插队、以及本该照看队伍和维持秩序的人在某种程度上背叛了队伍运作方式的感觉，这个深层故事，当你把你遇到并与之结为朋友的人的这个故事拿给他们看时，他们中的许多人告诉你，你捕捉到了让他们觉得真实的东西。所以，例如，许多自由派可能会说保守派被福克斯新闻洗脑了，你会说，不，福克斯的吸引力在于它们向人们证实了
that the deep story is true. Yes, well, I think it's a cyclical relationship because Fox News is a deep story news source. It begins with it, it firms it, it passes it on. But yeah, it's a fit for them. They watch it to confirm this worldview. It passes it on. But yeah, it's a fit for them. They watch it to confirm this worldview. And there's another part of what emerges from this deep story is that government is now
这个深层故事是真实的。是的，嗯，我认为这是一个循环的关系，因为福克斯新闻是一个深层故事的新闻源。它始于它，它巩固了它，它传递了它。但是是的，这对他们很契合。他们收看它是为了证实这种世界观。它传递了它。但是是的，这对他们很契合。他们收看它是为了证实这种世界观。还有一部分从这个深层故事中浮现出来的是，政府现在在其所有表现形式中都是
suspect in all of its manifestations. And that's a Fox News story, story too that the government had become an instrument of the line cutters. That's the implication of the deep story. As you point out, there's an irony here because, of course, many conservative states are poorer than liberal states. They use more government benefits than liberal states. As you point out, nearly half of Louisiana State budget comes from federal spending. So how do people reconcile the deep story, this antipathy toward people who are being helped by the federal government, with their own deep dependence on the federal government?
可疑的。这也是一个福克斯新闻的故事，即政府已经成为插队者的工具。这就是深层故事的含义。正如你所指出的，这里有一个讽刺意味，因为当然，许多保守派州比自由派州更穷。他们比自由派州使用更多的政府福利。正如你所指出的，路易斯安那州近一半的预算来自联邦开支。那么，人们如何将深层故事——这种对接受联邦政府帮助的人的反感——与他们自己对联邦政府的深度依赖调和起来呢？
Well, it's interesting. I spent five years asking that question. And when we think about tensions between social classes, liberals tend to look up at the 1% the Wall Street, the people that caused the 2008 crash, and that's where the tension is, you know, Occupy Wall Street. They look up the class ladder. People I came to know, the Tea Party advocates in Louisiana looked down the class ladder. The big tension line was between the middle class, blue collar class on one hand, and the welfare recipients and poor people on the other. And it's not that they don't know that their state is very poor.
嗯，这很有趣。我花了五年时间来问这个问题。当我们思考社会阶层之间的紧张关系时，自由派倾向于向上看，看到1%的人、华尔街、引发2008年崩溃的人，紧张关系就在那里，你知道，“占领华尔街”。他们向上看阶级阶梯。我结识的人，路易斯安那州的茶党倡导者，则是向下看阶级阶梯。主要的紧张线一方面在中产阶级、蓝领阶级之间，另一方面在福利领取者和穷人之间。这并不是说他们不知道自己的州非常贫困。
I asked people about that too. And the conclusion I came to is that they know about the red state paradox. It's not a matter of not knowing. But it's just less important than the deep story. The deep story has to do with people getting ahead of you unfairly who probably don't work as hard as you do, and I bet the rules as well as you do. That just gloomed larger. When we come back, I'm going to talk to Arley specifically about Donald Trump. Our conversation will be informed by a single, stark fact. 53 of Louisiana's 64 parishes are majority white. Hillary Clinton won 10 of the 11 parishes, where whites are not in the majority. Of the 53 majority white parishes, Donald Trump won all 53. Stay with us.
我也问过人们关于这一点。我得出的结论是，他们知道“红州悖论”。这并不是不知道的问题。但这只是比深层故事不那么重要。深层故事与那些不公平地走在你前面、可能工作不如你努力、遵守规则也不如你的人有关。这只是显得更大。当我们回来时，我将专门和阿利谈谈唐纳德·特朗普。我们的对话将基于一个单一而严峻的事实。路易斯安那州的64个教区中，有53个是白人占多数。希拉里·克林顿赢得了白人不占多数的11个教区中的10个。在53个白人占多数的教区中，唐纳德·特朗普赢了全部53个。请继续收听。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Arle you say that regardless of whether Donald Trump was making an argument that was in the economic self-interest of his audience, he was making an argument that was in their emotional self-interest. He made many of the people you talk with feel like they were no longer strangers in their own land. He seemed to be the guy against all of the line cutters, against blacks, against women, against
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。阿利，你说，不管唐纳德·特朗普提出的论点是否符合其受众的经济自身利益，他提出的论点是符合他们的情感自身利益的。他让你交谈过的许多人觉得，他们不再是自己土地上的陌生人。他似乎是那个对抗所有插队者、对抗黑人、对抗妇女、对抗
immigrants, against refugees, against public sector workers. I went with a member of the Tea Party to a Donald Trump rally in March, a day before the primary in New Orleans, and she coming out of this rally said, gosh, there aren't very many black people here. And in fact, the only black people I saw were insecurity and selling Donald Trump t-shirts out in the front lawn. And I asked her about that, and she just avoided the topic. So what are the points that you make is that conservatives feel that liberals have morally boxed them into a corner to express how you really feel about the poor, about people
移民、对抗难民、对抗公共部门工作人员的人。我在3月新奥尔良初选前一天，和一位茶党成员一起去参加了一个唐纳德·特朗普的集会，她在集会结束后说，天哪，这里黑人可真不多。事实上，我看到的唯一的黑人在安保部门，并在前草坪上出售唐纳德·特朗普的T恤。我问她这件事，她只是避开了这个话题。所以你的观点之一是，保守派觉得自由派把他们在道德上逼入了一个角落，去表达你对穷人、对有色人种、对妇女、对同性恋者的真实感受，
of color, about women, about gays, can expose you to charges that you are an uncarrying person or even a bigoted person. And one of the things that I think you're saying is that Trump's rhetoric gave people away to talk openly about their deep story, perhaps for the very first time. I think that's right, but you know, I got a sense of the complexity of racism. First of all, I got a sense of the complexity of racism. First of all, people did not feel that they were racist. One man, for example, said, well, a racist is someone who uses the N word. I don't ever use that word.
可能会让你面临你是一个冷酷无情的人甚至是一个偏执狂的指责。我想你所表达的一点是，特朗普的 rhetoric（修辞）为人们提供了一种公开谈论他们的深层故事的方式，也许是有史以来的第一次。我认为是这样的，但你知道，我体会到了种族主义的复杂性。首先，我体会到了种族主义的复杂性。首先，人们并不觉得自己是种族主义者。例如，一个人说，好吧，种族主义者是使用N开头的那个词的人。我从来不用那个词。
If somebody uses that word on my Facebook, I take them off my Facebook page. I'm offended by it. And the other definition of a racist is someone who hates Blacks. He said, I don't hate Blacks, but that, of course, leaves out a lot of kind of institutional expressions of racism. And they fell to the side given the primacy of this deep story. So speaking of the institutional ways in which race might play out, you point out that there are relatively few government regulations for things
如果有人在我的Facebook上使用这个词，我就会把他们从我的Facebook页面上移除。我对它感到被冒犯。而种族主义者的另一个定义是讨厌黑人的人。他说，我不讨厌黑人，但这当然忽略了许多种族主义的体制化表现。鉴于这个深层故事的至高无上性，这些都被抛到了一边。说到种族可能发挥作用的体制化方式，你指出，对于诸如枪支、摩托车或烈酒之类的东西，政府监管相对较少，但当涉及到堕胎或一个人的裤子穿得离内衣有多低时，却有很多监管。在我看来，这并不是那种千篇一律的
like guns or motorcycles or liquor, but there are lots of regulations when it comes to abortion or how low someone can wear his pants over his underwear. It seems to me this isn't sort of a one-size-fits-all. I don't want the government in my life philosophy. Not at all. It's fine if the government controls women or blacks in Louisiana.
“我不想让政府干预我的生活”的哲学。完全不是。如果政府在路易斯安那州控制妇女或黑人，那是可以接受的。
It has a kind of image of itself as a state, as a political culture of bravado and freedom the Wild West, but as you say, that didn't apply to women if an adult accompanies a teenager, say, rape victim something, to a nearby state to get an abortion. They can be jailed. So for people who don't want big government, they certainly allow an enormous role for government to make choices for the individual with regard to abortion. And there were a number of in local parishes ordinances about how low your pants could go, and this applied to black
它有一种把自己当作一个州、一种充满虚张声势和自由的政治文化——美国西部荒野——的形象，但正如你所说，如果一个成年人陪同一个十几岁的女孩（比方说强奸受害者什么的）去邻近州堕胎，这并不适用于女性。他们可能会被关进监狱。所以对于那些不想要大政府的人来说，他们当然允许政府在堕胎方面为个人做出选择方面发挥巨大作用。当地教区有许多关于你的裤子可以下垂多低的条例，这适用于黑人
teenagers. So very strange, and what would seem like government intrusion. Many of the women you spoke with obviously endorsed the conservative deep story, but you also point out that in some ways they are the victims of this deep story, that the deep story in some ways is resentful of women for being in the workplace, advancing in the workplace, perhaps at the expense of men. How do the women you speak with reconcile this tension between being subscribers to the deep story and also having the deep story, burst of the deep story and also having the deep story essentially try and exclude them. They handled that paradox in a variety of ways. Every woman that I spoke to worked. Blue collar women, you know, had to work middle class women. They all worked and they believed in equal pay for equal work.
青少年。所以这非常奇怪，而且看起来像是政府的侵入。你交谈过的许多女性显然认可保守派的深层故事，但你也指出，在某些方面，她们也是这个深层故事的受害者，这个深层故事在某种程度上对女性在职场中、在职场中取得进步（可能是以牺牲男性为代价）感到不满。你交谈过的女性如何调和这种矛盾：既是深层故事的信奉者，又让深层故事（本质上试图排斥她们的深层故事）在她们身上产生？她们以各种方式处理了这个悖论。我交谈过的每个女人都在工作。蓝领女性，你知道，必须工作，中产阶级女性。她们都工作，并且她们相信同工同酬。
At the same time, I think many of them felt protective of vulnerable blue collar white men. And as a class, this group was doing badly. Studies have shown outside of my book that they're more depressed, a higher suicide rate, more likely to not live with the mother of their children. So, some of the women who feel, okay, these high school educated white men, they're the kind of men I'm going to marry, have married, they're my brother, my father, my uncle, and let's get someone to answer the economic issues that face such men. So in this regard, they're thinking not of themselves as workers, but as wives and mothers. It feels like you're laying out for me something that is actually a paradox.
与此同时，我认为她们中的许多人对脆弱的蓝领白人男性感到保护。作为一个阶层，这个群体过得很糟糕。我的书之外的研究表明，他们更加抑郁，自杀率更高，更有可能不和他们孩子的母亲生活在一起。所以，一些感到“好吧，这些高中毕业的白人男性，他们是我要嫁的、已经嫁的男人，他们是我的兄弟、我的父亲、我的叔叔”的女性，希望有人来解决面临这些男性的经济问题。因此，在这方面，她们想到的不是自己作为工人，而是作为妻子和母亲。感觉你正在为我阐述一个实际上是悖论的东西。
Many of the people you spoke with, they're older, they're mostly white, many of them are men. They tell you they feel like they're strangers in their own land. But that's also the way the African-American man who gets repeatedly pulled over by the police also feels. That's also the way, you know, the undocumented Latina teenager who was brought to the country by her parents when she's a baby. that's how she feels too. And I feel like in many of our political debates, each side is saying, I feel so anxious that I am not welcome in this country. I must do something to take my country back and both sides feel this and they feel this
你交谈过的许多人，他们年龄较大，大多是白人，其中许多是男性。他们告诉你，他们觉得自己是自己土地上的陌生人。但这也是那个被警察屡次拦下的非裔美国男性的感受。这也正是那个被父母在婴儿时期带到这个国家的无证拉丁裔女青少年……这也是她的感受。我觉得在我们许多的政治辩论中，每一方都在说，我感到如此焦虑，以至于我不受欢迎在这个国家。我必须做点什么来把我的国家夺回来，双方都有这种感觉，而且他们对此感到
intensely and they feel the other side is responsible for their anxiety. Yes. this intensely and they feel the other side is responsible for their anxiety. Yes, I think that's right. I started this book with the Red State Paradox and Mind, but I ended it with the Blue State Paradox and Mind. What has been missing in the Democratic Party that it does not speak to the anxieties, the desire for recognition, the actual economic dilemmas in Rust Belt states and rural states in the south, that it's lost blue-collar and white voters. What's missing? Why didn't the Democratic Party stand up
强烈，并且他们认为对方应对他们的焦虑负责。是的，我认为这没问题。我带着“红州悖论”开始这本书，但我在结尾时带着“蓝州悖论”。民主党缺少了什么，以至于它没有去解决铁锈带州和南方农村州的焦虑、对认可的渴望、实际的经济困境，以至于它失去了蓝领和白人选民？缺少了什么？为什么民主党没有站出来，
and make sense to the people I came to know? That was the paradox I ended up with. Arlie Hoeksheel, I want to thank you for talking with me on Hidden Brain today. Thank you, I had great pleasure. Thank you, great pleasure. This week's podcast was produced by Maggie Penman and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Renee Clark, Raina Cohen and Chloe Connelly. Our unsung heroes this week are Sarah McCammon, who helped us with this podcast and her colleagues
并对那些我结识的人讲得通？这就是我最后得出的悖论。阿利·霍克希尔德，我要感谢你今天在《隐藏的大脑》中与我交谈。谢谢你，我非常高兴。谢谢，非常高兴。本周的播客由玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、蕾妮·克拉克（Renee Clark）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和克洛伊·康纳利（Chloe Connelly）。我们本周的无名英雄是萨拉·麦卡蒙（Sarah McCammon），她帮助我们制作了这期播客，还有她的同事们
on the NPR politics team. For the last 18 months, they have covered the political campaign tirelessly and as a new administration takes office, they're still at it. You should check them out at the NPR Politics Podcast. For more hidden brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, please tell one friend who doesn't know about us to follow our show. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR.
在NPR政治团队。在过去的18个月里，他们不知疲倦地报道了政治竞选活动，随着新政府的上台，他们仍在继续。你应该去NPR政治播客（NPR Politics Podcast）收听他们的节目。要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，并收听你在当地公共广播电台的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请告诉一个不了解我们的朋友关注我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。